[Musique]
bonjour yan monplaisir
bonjour monsieur via le tendon jouera
aux auditeurs chef de file de bp dans le
champ s'il ya eu cette réunion mensuelle
d'information de votre mouvement c'était
vendredi soir ps pilote une réunion san
miguel laventure vous nous confirmer ce
matin que miguel laventure est désormais
persona non grata chez vous écoutez je
sais pas si c'est le terme à utiliser
mais ce qui est vrai c'est que nous
considérons qu'il ne fait plus partie de
notre groupe
je tiens d'abord à rappeler que miguel
laventure n'a pas participé aux
discussions qu'il a eues avec le vent
semblait pour constituer cette nouvelle
majorité
donc je vais très clairement écarté le
fait qu'il puisse agir dans l'esprit de
qui que ce soit d'un problème de
personne d'ailleurs
nous sommes un groupe de six élus soit
l'exécutif soit présent soit l'exécutif
soit dans l'assemblée et cinq d'entre
nous à l'unanimité considère que ça ne
peut plus durer
alors notre accord a été discuté je les
dis hors de la présence 2000 il faut
remettre les choses en décembre 2015 si
vous permettez vendredi arrive non non
on y arrive on est en mission ecclésiale
monsieur je répondrai à toutes vos
questions je répondrai à toutes vos
questions mais laissez-moi expliquer
cela il faut que les refaire le match
non je ne refais pas le match explique
simplement que nous avons participé il y
avait si bien sa soutane marinette
torpille karine mousseau fred michel
giraud et moi même c'est moi qui
conduisais cette liste m'a payé en
chance et une liste de rassemblement qui
allait au-delà des clivages politiques
et j'ai dû imposer la présence de miguel
laventure et à certains de mes amis de
bas pays en chance et surtout aux
membres de du grand ensemble et est donc
c'est moi personnellement nous sommes
dans gm de tours de ce fait dans l'antre
de l'asti c'est moi personnellement qui
est imposé la présence de mineurs je
veux le dire parce que je veux pas qu'on
s'imagine que ce soit un problème entre
royal et miguel c'est un problème de
fond qui se pointent ce dakar est ce que
vous avez été correct est ce que vous
avez appelé miguel laventure pour le lui
dire personnellement solennellement
miguel tu n'est plus des nôtres alors
alors vous voyez c'est toute la
difficulté et c'est pour ça
google n'est pas dans une démarche
constructive et collaborative
il l'a il mène sa barque j'ai trois
appels téléphoniques avec message de
watsa et un mille âmes il ya de
l'aventuré pour lui dire je souhaite
m'entretenir échangé avec toi à au
moment où je vous parle je n'ai toujours
pas de réponse nous avons essayé de
jouer ce week-end comme vous mais
personne n'arrive à le joindre
c'est un des problèmes si les jours et
heures mais les porteurs de projet pose
la même problématique
ceux qui ont besoin de faire ils sont
tous ceux très accessible via mon
plaisir mais il avoue les n'avons pas de
dire exemple à bientôt à écouter mais
vous vous venez vous même de me dire que
il est dit mais bon y siègent pas du
tout et j'ai vite les mâles indiqué à as
tu as tenté de le joindre tous les os
vous savez moi je reçois des appels
d'abord tout le monde connaît mon numéro
de téléphone parce que je considère que
quand on est élu on est au service des
gens qui vous font confiance je donne
mon numéro de téléphone et je rappelle
systématiquement quand je ne peux pas
répondre tout de suite je rappelle
systématiquement toutes les personnes
qui m'appelle même quand le numéro de
téléphone ne me dis pas de qui il s'agit
c'est un principe c'est le respect de
l'électeur
oui vous êtes en train de dire que
miguel laventure des pas très
respectueux jeudi qu'il fait pas le job
ouais en tout cas il nous a fait
parvenir un communiqué au cours du
week-end ou disant qu' il avait été élu
en tant que bas pays acp en chance en
décembre 2015
donc qu'il est né lui quelque chose que
vous voudriez faire il demeure un élu de
bayonne n'avait pas le pouvoir de
l'exclusion évident qu'il demeure un élu
mais ce qui est vrai c'est qu'il n'est
pas nécessairement partis politiques non
on n'est pas un parti politique il a
raison et on n'exclut pas les gens
simplement nous ne les convions plus
dans nos réunions simplement nous ne
nous ne voulons plus être associé à une
image qui n'est pas celle que que nous
devons donner aux martiniquais
nous sommes un groupe qui est venu pour
travailler nous sommes un groupe qui à
la callas mission d'obtenir les
résultats il dit revenant écouter en
tout cas moi ce que je sais c'est que
les porteurs de projets ne sont pas
satisfaits ce que je sais c'est que les
porteurs de projets se plaignent ils se
plaignent en particulier auprès de moi
même parce que je suis chef d'entreprise
et auprès de marine et orbite par tels
les chefs d'entreprise que je suis
chargé du développement économique
dans l'assemblée et marinette est chargé
du développement économique à l'exécutif
et
nous avons en permanence des ghosts a
qui sont faits comment voulez-vous me
dire que l'on interdit au personnel de
la collectivité de donner des réponses
aux porteurs de projets sur l'état
d'avancement de leur projet c'est parce
que vous ne savez pas constituer les
dossiers c'est parce qu'on ne savait pas
jouer collectif
dixit miguel laventure même dans ce
studio dont gmail millions tu es là
encore j'en appelle à tous ces
témoignages que nous avons paix et si
nous en sommes arrivés là c'est parce
que ça n'est plus supportable
ça n'est plus supportable il faut que
miguel laventure se met au travail
il faut qu'au milieu de l'aventuré ne
soit plus dans le déni il ne faut pas
quand on lui dit que ça ne va pas qu'il
ait eu donc tout va bien et vous et vous
savez il ya des principes nous ne sommes
pas venus pour puisqu'il faut consommer
les fonds européens
nous ne sommes pas venus pour que faire
un gros dossier qui permette ou dix gros
dossier qui permettent de dépenser les
200 millions qu'on doit dépasser par des
pensées par an nous voulons que tous les
porteurs de projets et surtout les plus
petits parce que c'est là qu'il ya la
plus grande proportion de créations font
plaisir vous savez ce qui se dit
également s'est pas dites moi c'est chez
dans les dossiers que vous pourriez vos
prochains est menée concernant les fonds
de pays européens
que voulez pas obtenu satisfaction que
c'est pour ça que vous ruer dans les
brancards pas du tout pas du tout
monsieur viol dont ce n'est en fait je
ne sais pas j'ai entendu gens sentent
j'avais volé du dossier ont-ils touché
écoutez nous n'avons moins jeunes est en
ce moment à titre personnel aucun
dossier de fond robin en cours donc je
ne sais pas s'il ya d'autres élus qui
ont des dossiers mais à petit personnel
aucun et puis et puis atteints
d'hépatite c trop important faut pas
laisser ces sous-entendus
ce sont des sous entendus qui sont
malhonnêtes qui sont de mauvaise foi
- vous voyez je n'utilise pas mon mandat
d'élu pour obtenir ici et là des
prébendes pour moi ou pour ma famille et
je n'ai jamais demandé à qui que ce soit
d'embauché mes enfants dans aucune
entreprise vous parlez de cuisine je
écouter que ce qu'ils entendent
l'entendent autres moi je dirais plus
petit jeu les dix mots scolaire moi je
suis quelqu'un je suis quelqu'un de
profondément honnête je me bats pour les
martiniquais monsieur monsieur viol ton
et et les sous-entendus besson gars et
si je peux me réveillais d'enfer si je
peux m'exprimer oui mais ce qui me
concerne si je peux m'exprimer avec
force c'est parce que je suis
et je paie le prix de cette liberté
monsieur viol ton est ce que je fais
aujourd'hui je tire une sonnette
d'alarmé et je dis au président de
l'exécutif du conseil exécutif que nous
ne cautionnons pas qu'un autre groupe ne
cautionne pas un élu qui ne remplit pas
sa mission et il appartient maintenant à
monsieur marie-jeanne d'en tirer les
conséquences et ce que j'espère monsieur
viol dont c'est que cette cette
disposition que nous avons prise de dire
que cet élu là qui ne remplit pas sa
mission qui ne fait pas son travail qui
ne répond pas aux attentes des
martiniquais que cet élu là il faut que
le président de l'exécutif je le cite
encore une fois alfred marie-jeanne
l'obligent à faire sont à remplir sa
mission alors et si il ne le fait pas ce
sera de sa responsabilité et moi je
n'aurais pas été celui qui a cautionné
cela il ya le mot plaisir vous chasse un
homme plutôt loyal alfred marie-jeanne
on l'a dit tout le monde le reconnaît
que bigard l'aventuré plutôt loyal
alfred marie-jeanne mondial s'il a
plutôt fait considérée comme un acte de
guerre a deux en or la voisine surtout
pour le renouvellement de lasfaillades
ou pas du tout nous sommes
moi je suis dans la danse vous savez
souvent les gens me dis mais pourquoi
vous dites pas ceci pourquoi vous faites
pas se lier à la manoeuvre politique où
elle a déjà fait - et ses matériaux il
ya une solidarité indispensable au sein
d'un groupe
le groupe bat pays en chance et
quelquefois on doit faire partie de
cette solidarité
ce qui m'a conduit à ne pas dénoncer
plus tôt il ya une solidarité à voir
avec la majorité et je suis d'une
loyauté exemplaire monsieur viol toi et
je les dis et c'était moi dieu que tu
veux dire tout ça je les dis à alfred
marie-jeanne les yeux dans les yeux je
lui dis que le jo je ne suis plus
d'accord avec lui il le saura le produit
le premier et ensuite je le ferai savoir
publiquement
je suis dans cette majorité qui a des
résultats dans beaucoup de domaines mais
cott ça ne sont pas dire eos et en
particulier du groupe que j'ai conduit
il m'appartient de le faire savoir
il ya une ambiance détestable c'est de
cette majorité on va rappeler très
rapidement quelques faits ni l'or qui
crie son parti un drapeau qui est loin
de faire l'unanimité des travaux de
photos commandées pour aller voir ce qui
se passe ailleurs porte parole qui passe
son temps à vomir sur la plaie sur la
presse le président d'assemblée qui ne
s'entend plus avec son homologue est
égale du conseil exécutif jolie
l'ambiance vous écoutez moi ça me gêne
pas ce qui compte pour moi c'est qu'on
travaille
monsieur violoncelle ça ne vous gêne pas
aussi à voir ce sont des questions sur
le droit de la majorité
ils ont le droit ils doivent se poser
des questions ce qui m'intéresse c'est
que jamais le tourisme ne s'est aussi
bien porté ce qui m'intéresse c'est
qu'on a un taux de croissance maintenant
supérieur à celui de la guadeloupe alors
que la martinique était en récession ce
qui m'intéresse c'est qu'on construit
des écoles
ce qui m'intéresse c'est qu'on répond
aux problèmes sociaux des personnes des
personnes âgées des personnes
nécessitant son succès en salles
c'est pour ça messieurs suffisante on ça
n'est jamais suffisant ce qui compte
c'est de regarder par rapport aux autres
quand je me regarde je me désole quand
je me compare je me console est
aujourd'hui la martinique va mieux
nous avons évité la gabegie nous avons
évité la la fuite en avant
nous avons évité la situation de
faillite annoncée et vous savez quand
une collectivité est en faillite
on en arrive à ne plus pouvoir rien fait
je ne citerai pas d'exemple à la
martinique mais il y en a des quantités
donc nous sommes dans une démarche de
sérieux alors bien sûr ces neuf
enseignes vous êtes entre eupen déjà
pour la 7ème dans deux ans ça c'est vous
qui le dites moi je ne suis encore
monsieur regarde dans les yeux vous
n'êtes pas des gens tant pas non
monsieur viol temps je ne suis pas en
campagne je vous regarde dans les yeux
parce que monsieur viol ton monsieur
virton si j'étais en campagne je ne
ramènerai pas certain nombre
d'éclaircissements au moment où je le
fais je n'aurai pas le courage de dire
un certain nombre de choses je n'aurai
pas le courage date de d'assumer de
devoir aujourd'hui vous apportez à vous
et aux martiniquais des êtres ce matin
monsieur groupe les noms je suis
simplement déterminé
je veux que vous compreniez monsieur
viol dont je ne peux pas être fâché
monsieur le temps je suis simplement
quelqu'un de responsable et j'ai mal à
la martinique j'ai mal au travail que je
fais j'aime avoir entendu que vous avez
mal à miguel laventure ce matin on va
écouter quand quelqu'un ne fait pas le
travail comme quelques ne travaillent
pas suffisamment
quand quelqu'un ne répond pas aux
martiniquais quand quelqu'un quelques ne
s'engage pas comme il conviendrait il
m'appartient c'est ma responsabilité de
dire que ça ne peut pas continuer il ya
les causes il est faut il le fonds gérés
lit par exemple c'est pour les plus
petits c'est pour les plus faibles
c'est pour les porteurs de projets finis
yan monplaisir un homme responsable et
qui n'est pas encore pas nous dit il ce
matin dans son caddie yan monplaisir
chef de file de banque ayant chose qui
était dans son crédit se mater bonne
journée
ok